ich kenne das so eine tat auf youtube
ein tutorial gemacht diamanten finden in
drei minuten
hey leute in diesem video zeige ich euch
einfach mal wie in einer zufällig
generierten welt in minecraft eure
ersten diamanten innerhalb von nur fünf
minuten findet also ja und zwar das
mache ich da mal eben so ich habe mir
ein neues tutorial ist die tendenz
diamanten findet einer minute 13
sekunden durch den freunde und herzlich
willkommen zur capt auf minecraft nach
einer sehr sehr sehr sehr sehr sehr
spannenden folge letzten dabei komme wo
wir einfach mal wir haben die
verabschiedung gemacht oder 2005
silberfisch hobby an und alles mögliche
und wollen wir dieser folge wieder ein
bisschen mehr erreichen uns war der
letzte was erreicht wir haben das portal
gefunden haben diamanten gefunden und
jetzt da ich noch nicht den erfolg
diamanten abkommen würde ich sagen wenn
du das nicht bei diamanten findet sag
mir bescheid aber euch die ab genau
genau okay na gut ich hole mal eben die
diamanten für die spitzhacke damit wir
mal obsidian abbauen können was ist denn
der erfolg über dem diamant über dem
diamanten
da kommt keiner mehr da kommt also da
also man kann einmal diamanten
einsammeln wir für einen diamanten zu
einem anderen spieler lassen
ihr vater zu mir dann wird man einen
diamanten zu mir es bringt nichts los
das erz gott nein dieses portier die
zuversicht der los mit den zombies komme
ich mit anbauten an den wänden zeugen
oder schals sagen wollte alter von wo
kommen die denn überall höre überall
welche ich höre wieder leute sterben
komme weißt du was das bringt oli ist
auf den dungeon verstehst du das erz zu
werfen
es gibt doch kein ja man erst schmeißt
man einfach einen diamanten zu vertrauen
x naja
doch es gibt jemand erz
es gibt kein diamant erzeugt ein jammer
des abbaus kriegt ja direkt diamanten
ja genau war das ist schon ein erfolg
vor allem diamanten also ja aber du
musst es mir zu werfen so hatte ich aber
dass ich werde ja kein eisenerz zu was
du hier machst einfach mal gucken ob ich
portionen erstmal die wände zu wurde
über die diamanten runter ach nee was zu
bevor du dir in spezifischen spitzhacke
gemacht ich hätte noch einen aber nicht
die der mensch hat noch nie gemacht
ich komme es noch runter ok stark ja ich
wollte mal ganz kurz die wände einfach
zu uns kommt nicht bekommen
wahrscheinlich nie ich nicht aber du
hast weil du mir den dazu geworfen hast
acht so aber jetzt habe ich das noch
nicht wann immer du hast du noch keinen
diamanten zugeworfen ich stimmt und das
meine ich ja die ganzen sache ja ich
weiss man jemanden einfach zu wenig
getanzt
warum warum warum warum barack obama
guckt alleine ich nehme ich das ist
ziemlich cool so gut möchte und auch die
andern beiden zu werfen
du bist jetzt natürlich von mir sagte
aber ist ja egal hab ich nach oben macht
der spitzhacke ja dann kann das muss ich
doch abbauen du musstest abbauen das ist
natürlich klar ich muss aber wenn du
diamanten findest dann muss ich erstmal
die diamanten finden dann muss ich dir
abbauen und da hab ich dir die diamanten
zu damit ich noch das andere schiff
fährt bekomme ich auf dem platz hat er
erstmal wieder diamanten und wissen wie
wir haben ich glaube ich weiß welche
finden wir müssen uns einfach runter
bauen auf höhe 11 weil welche sind wir
gerade welche bin ich treu als er alles
neu hierbei fw33 das alles neu warte ich
komme sofort eine spitzhacke für dich
dann breche jetzt wieder den versand ist
plötzlich so krass dann brauche ich das
hier freuen doch noch was geht ab in die
city als neu wenn ich das hier noch raus
oder schwere kisten
jahrhundert so geht das hier gar nicht
so hier liegt auch ein ganz neuer
wiedergefunden hier ja keiner so
unterwegs jetzt neben apfel so dann
spaziert kann man das ist ein richtiges
ivm in folge hier richtig stark serie
richtig durch jäger werde ich bin da wo
bist du
warte mal ich bin hier trainer f3 allein
schon
dankeschön dankeschön aber es cooler
dass du siehst jetzt sogar die xyz
koordinaten diesem rot-grün teil bitte
alter das ja das ja cool so okay kommt
jetzt also minecraft stone minecraft
dirt wir brauchen nicht schaufel können
wir uns auch noch später schaffen
dann baut auch mal einarbeiten die
kommen erst mal mit ja wenn man genug
zeit übrig ich dort ja nicht jetzt soll
es hier noch wieder etwas gespart hier
müssen wir noch mal die seiten nachher
zu bauen
hier edulab noch nie sagt jetzt bei
obsidian ab aber pass auf dass du das
nicht lava runter ist
da passe ich auf und da ist auch noch
lava oder islam darunter acht was auch
dass da keine lava drunter ist
das war darunter ich bekomme das auch
nicht weg
was mache ich dann mal hier hin gekommen
aber jetzt jetzt exakt und gleich kommt
darum bat hat wieder umbau wir können
schon mal warm machen ganz langsam humba
humba
jetzt hat er was sein fachwissen noch
tiefer bei 1 portal zum leser aus
obsidian heißt sein dass die world
plauder unsichtbar ist bei mir auch
allerdings ein bisschen sieht man die
wenn man ganz genau hinschaut sieht man
diese ein bisschen naja vielleicht ist
das der trick dass ihr immer
unsichtbarer wird wir müssen aufpassen
mit der lava dann also ok ob sie dann
abbauen ist kein erfolg ein portal bauen
ist dann wieder ein erfolg ja dann mach
mal du baust du mal ein paar ab es ist
ja eben eine volk und ich gehe mal ganz
kurz nach oben
und weil hier die eingänge zu damit hier
nicht wieder zehn millionen sachen rein
spawnen okay so hier noch ein bisschen
höher da braucht man doch nur 12 ob sie
ihren drei unten drei oben ersten solo
ja du kannst ganz 1000 prozentig von
crafter ich bin 1000 ich bin mir
tausendprozentig sicher
wegen unserem diamanten 20 tierwelt zehn
millionen 1000 euro also youtuber geld
von einem tag wie gesamt diamanten
problem ich habe da einen vorschlag
ich fand es so eine tat auf youtube ein
tutorial gemacht diamanten finden in
drei minuten
ach so ja und zwar das mache ich da mal
eben das noch mal
das war schon ist ja profi glaube ich
ist ja der ist auch mittlerweile
multimilliardär und lebt in der villa in
bulgarien mafia leiter dort dann ehrlich
immer vier gegründet so ich mache das
aber immer okay in seinen drei minuten
wieder ich stoppt die zeit da nur also
kanten minute 7
ich geb gas ich will spaß ich bin sehr
gespannt muss auf höhe 11
also ich rauskomme oder einfach um ein
portal aus
echtes muss aber aufpassen wenn du dir
zu verbrennen ich bin hier der profi ach
so ja ja ja ja schwer vergessen habe ich
eine dumme frage von mir ja ich sehe
wieder so wird so ich bin unterwegs hier
ein bisschen wie zack zack zack
er ist 30 sekunden unterwegs
das tor
ich bin auch ich bin auch ich bin auf
höhe 11
okay das sehr gut und jetzt ja ganz ganz
geile jetzt sitzt da wird hier auf
dieser höhe sind greifen wir so ich sehe
schon bedrock sehr gut auf höher 11
verbunden da hat kommt joao kaputt auch
momente oder wegs durch gras man hier
die ganze kacke hier so ich hab euch
tutorial ich war neues tutorial ist die
toleranz diamanten findet einer minute
13 sekunden da sein ist sich dann ernst
ich habe aber keine eile mehr
aber ich hab' diamanten sicht eine das
ist kommt jetzt nicht abhauen clubs
chinas junge mitbruder ich hätte gedacht
dass ein rumpsteak karas das mich jetzt
nicht max darauf wegen dem was wir
kriegen keine tiefen
ja weil wir schon haben du musst noch
nicht doch doch hast du bist doch ja
doch doch steht jetzt auch die nächsten
ja kollege mir ruhig ihn wieder so
darstellen als mary mac wird für einen
diamanten entgegen erfolg kommt der
rasen noch läuft fast verwende ein buch
obsidian und die jva also wenn das kein
daumen hoch für und kraft gibt jetzt in
dem fall und witzig habe ich habe ja
schon so ein wenig verarscht damit ich
dachte jetzt kommt
bla bla aber der spaß einfach
also ich meine ich meine ich meine ich
habe die kamera suchen diamanten finden
minecraft fünf minuten erholt die dias
einfach gut hab ich gesagt dass ich gut
das habe ich komme erst jetzt jedem
alter peking ein
ich wusste dass ich ich muss halt
projekt jetzt ja wohl nicht mehr mit dir
machen einmal das jetzt alleine hier
ich wollte kickl berechtigung ich hab
der op weggelobt herrlich doch noch weit
entfernt wie eine neue waage cs hat das
war ich nicht moment mal 20 jahren wird
mein jetzt habe ich jetzt eine diamant
spitzhacke auch noch sehr sehr stark
sehr sehr geil
du hast du arsch und ich habe einfach
nicht zurück einmal zu viel den erfolg
nimmt sich der wandel geht ja ja ich hab
grad mit eisenspitzen obsidian abgebaut
weil du dir spitzer christ und ich für
den erfolg in einer minute diamanten 100
unterschiede hier der nahrungskette obst
jetzt oben wo ich hingehöre
damit ich die langweilige auftritt aber
noch in meiner folge hier schon davon in
einer folge das hier geschafft habe sie
liegt dort jetzt diesen ja der gleiche
das war so witzig dies beschloss jetzt
holt sie durch neigen wie leitern finde
ich die uns ganz nach unten führen weil
immer diese treppen laufen habe ich auch
gemacht meine zehen iren stimmten mit
dem laster hatte beinen das schon so
eine sache
ich habe auch schon was uns weiterbringt
leiter unter fünf minuten gemacht jetzt
einen schritt in unter fünf minuten ehe
das schaffe ich in unter zehn minuten
weil sie schon eine schwierige sache
naja eben wie viel leichter brauchst du
dein kollege sonnenschein schätze mal 30
bis nach ganz unten ja gut ich hab jetzt
7000 leiter gemacht obwohl und nach oben
bauen
ja ich erinnere mich aber gar nichts zu
essen wäre hier auch schon wieder ich
muss jetzt einfach die nase putzen
putzen unter fünf sekunden
fest steht kommt leute wir kriegen das
in die trends bei twitter dass wir
richtig geil hashtag in unter fünf
sekunden oder vivat niveau nee ich will
mich ich will wie diesem ich will mich
damit er nicht so fühlen
ich nehme das einfach mal so hin wenn
wir irgendwann sagt hier kommen ist
jetzt ein video gemacht es geht auch gar
nicht einfach in einer minute kommt der
witz zählen obsidian brauche ich echt
nicht mehr
hast du noch knochenmehl ich brauche
euch nicht mehr knochenmehl habe ich gar
nichts hast du bei mir alles ausgegeben
für diese kunst und dauerhaft als sogar
das geld getötet hat ich habe keine
knochen ja kein knochen mich am 0
doch sonst getötet hat das keinen knopf
gedrückt
doch hier 2 ich habe glaube ich bin wo
wollen wir ins portal bauen wo soll ich
das bond
portal bauen und beim sound würde ich
vorschlagen
beide staaten haben vielleicht hier oder
da oben oder wir bauen uns etwas hoch
das ist gut denn wir das weiter oben
bauen war ja noch so lange nach oben das
werk killer ja eben drauf wohl die
knochen und ich mache jetzt mal unsere
fahrer so ein bisschen größer heben ich
brauche mal diese scheiß gleise habe
damit das bringt ja nichts zwei
kilometer am stück fahren diesen erfolg
machen wir immer den ganzen ende des
projekts und nicht die quote bei lucca
so danke danke
hier kommen alle hände heute euch auch
schon soll dann kommt ein paar außerdem
hinter gebracht schlimm diesel ihres
noch auf das ist sehr gut das ist echt
guten papa mach mal stimmt wir können
doch dafür vereinigt schweine auch bahn
ja kann ich auch jetzt meine frage wie
komme ich eigentlich wieder runter wo
die kleine panne
ich hab gerade das kommt davon wenn man
keine leiter mitnimmt ich hab damals
nach leichten hochkommen bomben sich mal
hoch hier auch hilfe meine retter dann
notieren
du wirst einfach so schön ich hatte auch
gerade ich lass mal lieber ich werde
sterben
wie schafft neu eine gut ich würde sagen
wenn diese volk ein hochverdienter dabei
nicht das recht sich ohne darüber
endlich nicht nur leider mal wieder hier
rein und die ganzen anderen sachen bei
mir nahrung und alles fehlt aber na ja
gut ich packe erst mal wieder so ein
paar sachen hier so ein paar wichtige
sachen und da wird wie die ganzen
anderen scheiß machen dann will ich
sagen es euch gefallen hat was die werte
und damit sie in der nächsten folge
morgen bei komme wieder und dann will
ich mit
courage